The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: All right.
So good morning, everyone.
I'm Armando Solar-Lezama.
I'm giving the lecture
today on symbolic execution.
How many of you here are
familiar with what the term is
or have heard about it before?
We want to get a
sense of audience.
OK.
So let's see.
I dropped this machine
a little too many times
and it takes a while to boot up.
So symbolic execution
is really the workhorse
of modern program analysis.
It's one of those techniques
that has really broken out
of the research bubble
and actually made it
into a very large number of
high impact applications.
For example, today
at Microsoft there's
a system called SAGE that runs
on a lot of important Microsoft
code ranging from
PowerPoint to Windows
to actually find security
problems and security
vulnerabilities.
There's a lot of that
academic projects that
have made a lot of
real world impact
by discovering important
bugs in open source software,
for example, by relying
on symbolic execution.
And the beauty of symbolic
execution as a technique
is that compared to
testing, for example,
it gives you the
ability to reason
about how your program
is going to behave
on a potentially infinite
set of possible inputs.
It allows you to
explore spaces of inputs
that would be completely
unfeasible and impractical
to explore by, say,
random testing,
or even by having a very
large number of testers
banging and the code.
On the other hand, compared
to more traditional
static analysis techniques
it has the advantage
that when it discovers a
problem it can actually
produce for you an
input and a trace
that you can run on
your real program
and execute that
program on that input.
And you can actually tell
that it is a real bug.
And you can actually
go and debug it
using traditional
debugging mechanisms.
And this is
particularly valuable
when you're in an industrial
development environment
where you probably
don't have time
to go looking after every
little problem in your code.
You really want
to be able to tell
the difference
between real problems
versus false
positives, for example.
So how does it work?
So in order to
really understand how
it works it's useful to
start by looking at just
normal execution, right?
If we think of
symbolic execution
as a generalization of
traditional, plain execution,
it makes sense to know
what this looks like.
So I'm going to be using this
very, very simple program
as an illustration for
a lot of what I'm going
to be talking about today.
So what do we have here?
Again, it's a very simple
piece of code, just
a couple of branches and
here we have an assertion,
assert false.
And we want to know could that
assertion ever be triggered.
Is it possible?
Is there some input where that
will make that assertion fail?
And in this case because the
assertion is just saying,
assert false, what
I'm really asking is,
is there an input that can
reach that point in the program?
So one of the things I can
do is I can try just testing.
I can go in and run this
code with a concrete input.
Right?
So let's say that I start
with an input where x is 4
and y is 4.
And initially t is going
to have the value 0
right after I declare it.
So before we go with
normal execution,
what are some of the
important point here?
The fact that we need some
representation of the state
of the program, right?
Whether we're doing
normal execution
or whether we're doing
symbolic execution,
we need to have some
way to characterize
the state of the program.
And in this case, this
is such a simple program
that it doesn't use the heap.
It doesn't use the stack.
There are no function calls.
So the state can be fully
characterized by these three
variables together
with knowledge of where
in the program I'm at, right?
So if I start
executing with 4, 4,
and 0, so when I get to this
branch, is 4 greater than 4?
Clearly not.
So then I'm going to be
executing t equals y.
So now after I do
that t is no longer 0.
It now has the value 4.
Right?
So that is now the
state of my program.
And then I can
evaluate this branch.
Is it the case that
t is less than x?
No.
Right?
So we dodged the bullet.
We did not get an
assertion failure.
There was no problem in
this particular execution.
Right?
But that doesn't
really tell us anything
about any other execution.
All we know is that
under the input
x equals 4 and y equals 4, the
program is not going to fail.
But it tells us nothing
about what's going to happen
on the input
[? 2, 1, ?] for example.
Right?
And in this input you see
that this input is actually
going to follow a different
path in the execution.
This time we're actually
going to see that t equals x.
We're actually going
to set t equals 2x.
So after executing these
t will be equal to 2,
but is there any problem
in this execution?
Will there be an assertion
failure on this input?
Well, so let's see.
So if t is 2.
And x is 2.
Is t less than x?
No.
So it looks like we
dodged a bullet again.
Right?
So here we have two
concrete inputs.
And they told us that on
these two concrete inputs
the program didn't fail.
But that really doesn't tell us
anything about any other input.
And so the idea with
symbolic execution
is we want to go beyond these
single input executions.
And we want to be able
to actually reason
about the behavior of
the program on very
large sets of inputs.
In some cases, infinite
sets of possible inputs.
And the basic idea
is as follows.
So for a program
like this, just like
before the state
of the program is
characterized by the
value of these three
different variables.
Right? x, y, and t together with
knowing where in the program
I'm at.
But now instead of
concrete values for x and y
what I'm going to have
is a symbolic value, just
a variable.
A variable that allows me
to give a name to this value
that the user is going
to provide at the input.
So what that means is that
the state of my program
is no longer a mapping
from variable names
to concrete values.
It's now a mapping from variable
names to these symbolic values.
And a symbolic value,
you can essentially
think of it as a formula.
So in this case the
formula for x is just x.
And the formula for y is just y.
And for t, it's
actually the value 0.
We know that for every input,
doesn't matter what you do.
The value of t after the first
statement is going to be 0.
But now here's where
it gets interesting.
So we get to this
branch right here
that says, if x
is greater than y,
we're going to go
in one direction.
If it's less than
or equal to y, we're
going to go in the
other direction.
Now do we know
anything about x and y?
What do we know about them?
We know their type, at least.
So that's a start.
So we know that they're going
to be ranging from min int
to max int, but that's about
all we know about them.
And it turns out
that this information
that we know about them is not
sufficient to tell us which
direction this branch might go.
This branch could go either way.
And so now there are many
things and we can do,
but what's one possible thing
that we could do at this point?
Make a wild guess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Yeah.
We could follow both branches.
We could flip a coin and pick
one branch and take that.
So if we want to
follow both branches
we have to follow one and
then the other one, right?
So let's say we start
with this branch.
Right?
So now we are at this branch.
So what we know is that if
we make it to this branch,
in this branch t is now going
to have the same value as x.
And we don't know what
that value is going to be,
but we have a name for it.
It's this script letter x.
Right?
So that's the value
of t on that branch.
If we were to take the opposite
branch then what would happen?
The value of t would be
something different, right?
In that branch, the value of t
would be the symbolic value y.
So that means that when we get
to this point in the program,
what is the value of t?
Well, maybe it's x.
And maybe it's y.
We don't know exactly which
one it is, but why don't we
give it a name?
Let's call it t0.
And what do we know about t0?
What are the cases where t0
is going to be equal to x?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
That's right.
So essentially what we know is
that if x is greater than y,
then this implies that it's x.
And if x is less than or equal
to y that implies that it's y,
right?
And so we have this
value that we've defined.
We'll call it t0.
And it has these
logical properties.
So at this point in
the program we actually
have a name for the value of t.
It's t0.
Right?
And so what did we do here?
We took both branches
of this if statement.
And then we computed
the symbolic value
by looking at under
what conditions
am I going to take one branch,
under what conditions am I
going to take another branch?
And then looking
at what values am
I going to be assigning to
t on both of those branches?
So now it comes to the
point where we have to ask,
can t be less than x?
Right?
So what is the value of t?
The value of t is now t0.
So what we want
to know is, is it
possible for t0
to be less than x?
Right?
Now remember the
first branch we hit
we were asking a
question about x and y.
And we knew nothing
about x and y.
The only thing we
knew about x and y
was that they were of type int.
But now with t0 we actually
know a lot about t0.
We know that t0 is going to
be equal to x in some cases.
And it's going to be
equal to y in some cases.
And so this now gives
us a set of equations
that we can solve for.
So what we can say is,
is it possible to satisfy
t0 less than x knowing
that t0 satisfies
all of these properties?
Right?
So, in fact, we can
actually express this
as a constraint where we say,
so is it possible to have t0
less than x?
And to have x greater than
y implies t0 equals x.
And x less than or equal
to y imply t0 equal y.
Right?
So what we have here is an
equation that if that equation
has a solution, if it's
possible to find a value of t0,
and a value of x, and a value of
y that satisfies that equation,
then we know that those
values, when we plug them
into our program, when
the program executes,
it will take this branch.
And it will blow up when
it hits a assert false.
Right?
So what did we do here?
So we're executing this
program, but instead
of keeping our state as a
mapping from variable names
to values, what
we're doing is we're
keeping our program as a
mapping from variable names
to these symbolic values.
Essentially, other
variable names.
And in this case our
other variable names
are the script x, script
y, t0, and on top of that,
we have a set of
equations that tell us
how those values are related.
So we have an
equation that tells us
how t0 is related to
x and y in this case.
And solving for
that equation allows
us to answer the question
of whether this branch can
be taken or not.
Now just looking
at the equation,
can this branch be taken or not?
Right?
So it looks like the
branch cannot be taken.
Why not?
Because we're looking for
cases where t0 is less than x,
which means that if you're
in this case, then clearly
that's not going to be true.
Right?
So that means that when
x is greater than y,
then it cannot happen because
t0 will be equal to x.
And it cannot be equal to x and
less than x at the same time.
And what about in this case?
Can it happen in this case?
Can t0 be less than
x in this case?
No, it clearly cannot, right?
Because in this case we
know that x is less than y.
And so if t0 is going
to be less than x,
then it would also
be less than y.
But we know that in that case
t0 is exactly equal to y.
And therefore, again, that
case cannot be satisfied.
So what we have here is an
equation that has no solution.
It doesn't matter what values
you plug into this equation.
You cannot solve it and that
tells us that no matter what
inputs we pass to this code, it
will not go down this branch.
Now notice that when
making that argument here
I was basically alluding to
your intuition about integers,
about mathematical integers.
In practice we know that
machine ints don't quite
behave exactly the same
way as mathematical ints.
And there are some
cases where laws
that apply to mathematical
ints don't actually
apply to ints in programs.
And so when reasoning
about this we
have to be very
careful that when
we're solving these
equations, we're
keeping in mind
that these are not
the integers as they were taught
to us in elementary school.
These are 32-bit integers
that the machine uses.
And there are many
cases and many instances
of bugs that arose because
programmers were thinking
about their code in terms
of mathematical integers,
and not realizing that there
are things like overflows that
can cause the program
to behave differently
for mathematical inputs.
But the other thing is
what I've described here
is a purely intuitive argument.
I walk you through the process
of how to do this by hand,
but that's by no
means an algorithm.
Right?
The beauty of this idea
of symbolic execution,
however, is that it can be
coded into an algorithm.
And it can be solved in
a mechanical way, which
allows you to do this not
just for ten line programs,
but actually for
million line programs.
And it allows you
to actually take
this reasoning, and the
same intuitive reasoning
that we used in
this case to talk
about what happens
when we execute
this program on
different inputs.
And scale that reasoning
to very large programs.
Are there any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if a
[INAUDIBLE] are not
supposed to take an input?
[INAUDIBLE]
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Oh.
That's a very good question.
Right, so, for
example, let's say
we have the program that
we have here, but instead
of these being t equals x, here
we will say t equals x minus 1.
Right?
So now all of a
sudden, intuitively you
can see that now this
program could blow up, right?
Because when the program
takes this path then
t will indeed be less than x.
And you will indeed fail here.
Right?
So what will happen to
a program like this?
How will our symbolic
state look like?
Right?
So in this case, so t0,
when x is greater than y,
what is t0 now going
to be equal to?
It's not going to be equal to x.
It's going to be equal
to x minus 1, right?
And so that means that,
so, this condition now
has a satisfying assignment.
Right?
Now this can fail, but what
if you go to the developer
and say, hey, this
function can blow up
whenever x is greater than y.
And the developer
looks at this and says,
oh, I forgot to tell you.
Actually, this
function can never
be called with parameters
where x is greater than y.
Right?
That the client that calls
this function is just
a quick function that
I wrote for something.
And it has this branch for
some historical purpose.
But actually this
function will never
get called with
x greater than y.
You're like, well,
now you tell me.
Right?
But the way we can
think about this
is that there is an assumption
that x is going to be less than
or equal to y, right?
This is sometimes referred to
as a precondition or a contract
for this function.
The function is promising
to do something,
but only if you satisfy
this assumption.
And if you don't satisfy the
assumption, the function says,
I don't care what happens.
I only promise
that I'm not going
to fail when this
assumption is satisfied.
And it's the
responsibility of the color
to make sure that this condition
is never violated, right?
So how would we
encode that constraint
when we're solving
for equations?
Well, essentially
what we have is
we have this set
of constraints that
tell us whether this
branch is feasible.
And on top of the constraints
that we already have
we need to also make sure
that the precondition,
or the assumptions
are satisfied.
Right?
And now we want to
ask, OK, so can I
find an x and a y that satisfy
all of these constraints
together with these constraint
that I have on the input,
with these properties
that I know
that the input must satisfy?
And once again you can
see that this constraint
of x less than or equal
to y is the difference
between this constraint
being satisfiable,
and this constraint once
again becoming unsatisfiable.
That's a very important issue
when dealing with analysis,
especially when you want
to do this marginally
at the level of individual
functions at a time.
It makes sense to know
what the assumptions are
that the programmer
had in mind when
writing this function,
because if you don't know what
those assumptions were
you could say, yeah, here
are some inputs where it's going
to fail only for the programmer
to dismiss myth that by saying,
oh, but those inputs are not
possible, or those
inputs can never happen.
Other questions?
All right.
So how do we do this in
a more mechanical way?
So there are two
aspects to this problem.
Aspect number one is
how do you actually
come up with these formulas?
So in this case it
was kind of intuitive
how we came up
with the formulas.
where we were just working
through it by hand,
but how do you come
up with these formulas
in a mechanical way?
And aspect number two is
once you have the formulas,
how do you actually solve them?
How can you actually
solve these formulas
that describe whether
your program fails or not?
And I'm actually going to start
with that second question.
Given that we're able to reduce
our problem to these formulas
that involve integer
reasoning that involved
in the case of
programs generally
you care about bit
vector reasoning.
[INAUDIBLE] programs, a lot of
times, you care about arrays.
You care about functions.
And you end up with
these giant formulas.
How in the world do you actually
solve them in a mechanical way?
And a lot of the technology
that we're talking about today,
and the reason why we're
actually talking about it
as a practical tool, have to
do with tremendous advances
in solvers for
logical questions.
And in particular, there
is a very important class
of solvers called satisfiability
modulo theory solvers,
often abbreviated as SMT.
But a lot of people
in the community
would argue that the name is
not a particularly good name,
but it's the one that everybody
uses and it has stuck.
What you need to know
about these SMT solvers
is that an SMT solver is
an algorithm essentially
that given a logical
formula will give you
one of two things.
it will give you either
a satisfying assignment
to the formula, or
it will tell you
that the formula
is unsatisfiable.
And that there is no
possible assignment
to the variables in
that formula that
will satisfy these
constraints that you defined.
Now in practice, if this
sounds a little bit scary
and a little bit like magic,
it is a little bit scary.
A lot of the problems that
these SMT solvers have to solve
are NP-complete
in the best case.
All right? the nice
ones are NP-complete.
The hard ones can get
much harrier than that.
So how can we have a system that
relies as its primary building
block on solving NP complete
PSPACE-complete problems?
And still have something
that works in practice?
And part of the answer is that
for a lot of these solvers
there is a third thing
that they can tell you,
which is, I don't know.
And so part of the
beauty of these solvers
is that for practical
problems, even
for very, very large and
complicated practical problems,
they are still able to do
better than simply telling you,
I don't know.
They are still able
to give you either
a guarantee that this
set of constraints
is unsatisfiable or an actual
satisfying assignment that
tells you exactly
what the answer is.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
For example, [INAUDIBLE]
specification I don't
think you said anything
about how many bits are used to
store an integer. [INAUDIBLE]
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
That's a very good question.
And that really has
to do with how you
define your constraints, right?
So If you look at our simple
example from the beginning,
in this case, we assume that
these were the integers as
learned in elementary school.
And that we completely decided
to ignore overflow errors.
If you care about
overflow errors,
if overflow errors are actually
essential to the kind of bugs
you're trying to find, this
would not be a good way
to set up the problem.
What you need is to represent
these not so fast integers,
but as bit-vectors.
And the moment you represent
them as bit vectors
you have to have a
bit width in mind.
And this goes back to
what this modular theory
aspect in the solver means.
What this modular
theory aspect means
is that the solver is
actually extensible
with different theories.
The most popular theories are
the theory of bit-vector which
are fixed length bit-vectors.
That means that if you're
interpreting your formulas
in this theory of fixed
length bit-vectors
you have to fix the
length of the bit-vectors.
And you have to
explicitly specify
that these are going to be
32-bit bit-vectors, or 8 bit
bit-vectors, or
64-bit bit-vectors.
AUDIENCE: So if you wanted
to make the the bit symbolic
[INAUDIBLE], like this
is an x bit, is that--
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: So
there's another theory which
is called the theory of arrays.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about it,
where unlike the
bit vector theory,
which is designed to be
for fixed length things
the theory of arrays is meant
to be for collections where
you don't actually
know the size a priori.
Now in practice
nobody uses the theory
of arrays to model
integers, for example,
because it's too expensive.
It becomes way more
expensive to reason about
when you don't know
what the bound is.
So generally people
use fixed length theory
of bit-vectors when reasoning
about integers or characters
even.
Another very common theory is
the theory of actual integer
arithmetic, and in particularly
linear integer arithmetic.
This is a theory that
people like a lot because it
can be reasoned about
very, very efficiently,
but it's not
particularly good when
you're reasoning about programs,
because in general you really
do care about overflow issues.
But it's actually very widely
used for many, many things.
The other theory that you're
likely to see people using
is the theory of
uninterpreted functions.
So what does it mean, the theory
of an uninterpreted function?
It means that you have a formula
where somewhere in your formula
you know that you're
calling a function,
but you know nothing
about that function
other than the fact that it is
a function, that if you give it
the same inputs you get
the same outputs in return.
And it turns out this is
very, very useful sometimes
when trying to
reason about things
like if you floating point
code, modeling, sine, cosines,
square roots can be very
messy and expensive,
but you can say,
look, I don't actually
care about what the
sine function does.
I don't care about
what its output is.
All I know is that if I
call the sine function
in many different
places with the input
I will get the same output.
And that's enough for me
to reason about my code.
And so the most
common ones you will
see when analyzing
real systems are
bit-vectors to deal
with integers, and logs,
and pointers.
Actually, pointers are often
represented with integer
because you're
generally not going
to be doing complicated
bit whittling on pointers.
Sometimes you will and then
you can't use integers anymore.
So OK.
So that's all well and good.
That's what an SMT
solver can do for you.
How does it actually work?
What's inside it
that makes it work?
And SMT solvers actually
rely on our ability
to solve SAT problems,
on our ability
to take problems involving
just purely Boolean constraints
and Boolean variables,
and telling us
whether there is an assignment
to these Boolean variables
that is satisfiable or not.
And this is the kind of thing
that for many, many years
people in undergrad have been
taught that actually this
is an NP-complete problem.
The moment something
reduces to SAT
you know you shouldn't
do it, but it turns out
that we actually have
some very, very good SAT
solvers out there.
Probably most of you even
built one as part of 6005.
Am I right?
Or some of you did.
So I'll tell you the basic idea
behind how SAT solvers work.
And the basic idea is that
you take all your constraints
on your Boolean variables and
you put them into a database.
And what is a constraint?
Is this too small or can
people in the back read this?
AUDIENCE: Too small.
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Too small?
OK.
Let's see if we can
make this bigger.
Is this a little bit better?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: OK.
Well, here's what I'll do.
I will annotate and I
will narrate it as I go.
And I'll post the slides later.
So people can see what it says.
So what we have
here in SAT problem
is that we have all these
variables that represent
Boolean unknowns, right?
We want to know is
it possible for x
to be true, and y to be true,
and z to be true at the same,
for example.
Right?
And these are our unknowns.
And all the constraints are
in conjunctive normal form.
What that means is
all our constraints
are of the form either x1
is true, or x2 is true,
or x3 is true, for example.
Right?
So what we have is we have all
our constraints in this form
and some of them might say,
well, either x1 is true,
or x2 is false, or x3 is false.
Right?
So we have constraints.
All our constraints
are of this form.
And you probably remember
from discrete math
that any Boolean formula
can be represented
in conjunctive normal form.
And it has the added benefit
that it's actually very, very
easy to translate from arbitrary
representations of a formula
to these conjunctive normal form
formula, which means whatever
representation you're using
to represent Boolean formulas,
you can very easily
convert it to this format.
So what we have is
we have a database
with lots of constraints
of this form.
And what SAT solver
is going to do
is going to pick one of
these variables at random.
Let's say it's going to pick x1.
And it's going to say, why
don't we set x1 to true?
I don't know anything
about this problem.
Might as well try
selling it to true.
And then what will happen is
you'll have some constraints
that mention x1 and let's say
that you have a constraint that
says either x1 is
false or x7 is true.
Right?
So if you know that
x1 is true and you
know that either x1 is
false or x7 is true,
what do you know about x7?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Yeah.
It has to be true.
Right?
Because otherwise
this constraint
would not be satisfied.
And so now you've propagated
this assignment from x1 to x7.
And let's say now you pick
some other random variable.
You say, well, what about x5?
Why don't we try x5 being true?
Right?
And now let's say that you
have a constraint that says,
well, either x7 is false, or
x6 is true, or x5 is false.
Right?
So I have x5 being true
and I have x7 being true.
So that means x6
now has to be true.
Right?
Because otherwise this
constraint would be violated.
And so from that the
system infers, OK.
So x6 has to be true.
And it keeps at this
process essentially
trying out assignments.
And then looking at all
the available clauses,
and looking at,
hey, are there are
other things that are
implied by the assignments
that I have so far?
And following those implications
until one of two things
happens.
Either you keep following
implications and trying
random things and eventually
you have set a value
to every single
variable without ever
running into a contradiction.
And then you're done.
Right?
You found a satisfying
assignment, or what can happen
is you run into a contradiction.
You run into a place where there
was a clause that forced x4
to be true, except there was
another clause that forced x4
to be false.
And if there's one rule of
Boolean algebra that everybody
should know, is that you cannot
have a variable be true and be
false at the same time.
Right?
And so what that
tells you is you've
run into a contradiction.
You clearly did
something wrong in one
of these random assignments
that you were trying.
So now let's analyze
this contradiction.
Let's figure out what
were the assignments that
led to this contradiction.
And based on the assignments
that led to that contradiction,
let's come up with a
new conflict clause that
summarizes that contradiction.
So in this case,
what would happen
is that you have x1 being
false, and x5 being false.
And x9 being false, right?
So essentially what this is
saying is that based on what I
learned from these random
assignments I discovered that
one of these things
has to be true,
that it cannot be the case that
x1 is true, and x5 is true,
and x9 is false.
That cannot happen.
And I know that cannot happen
because when I tried that
things blew up.
I ended up with a contradiction.
And so what SAT solver is doing
is trying random assignments,
propagating them through.
When it runs into
contradictions it's
analyzing the set
of implications
that led to that contradiction.
And summarising that in
a new constraint that
will make sure
that it never runs
into this contradiction
again, that it never
runs into this
particular problem again.
Other questions?
OK.
So so far so good.
So we can't really
think of the SAT solver
as just a black box that
given a Boolean constraint
it can either say, no,
this Boolean constraint is
unsatisfiable, or it
can say, yeah, here's
a satisfying assignment to
that Boolean constraint.
So SMT solvers are built
on top of SAT solvers.
And what they're
able to do is they're
able to combine the
power of the SAT solver
to solve these NP-complete
SAT problems with domain
specific reasoning to reason
about the different theories
that are supported.
So to give you an
idea of how it works,
and this is going to
be a fairly high level,
but to give you
an idea of how it
works let's say that you have
a formula like this, right?
So you say x is greater
than 5 and y is less than 5.
And either y is greater than
x or y is greater than 2.
Right?
So is that satisfiable?
Can we find a satisfying
assignment for that?
So what an SMT solver can
do is separate out the part
of this formula that requires
domain reasoning, that
requires reasoning in
the theory, in this case,
of integers.
With the part of
this formula that
is just the Boolean structure.
So if you separate the
Boolean structure here,
essentially what
you're saying is
that there's some formula,
F1 and some formula F2,
and either F3 or F4.
Right?
And now this is a purely
Boolean problem, right?
It's just a problem of
can I find a satisfying
assignment for that?
Is there a satisfying
And, again, this is
just a Boolean formula.
Goes to a SAT solver and the
SAT solver can say, yeah.
I can find a satisfying
assignment for this.
And I can find a
satisfying assignment
by making this true, and
this true, and this true.
Right?
It's a satisfying assignment
for the Boolean formula.
So now we have a question
that we can go and ask
the domain specific solver.
In this case just a
linear arithmetic solver.
So we can go to
the linear solver
and say, hey, so the
SAT solver claims
that this is a reasonable
assignment, that if I
can make that
assignment work, then
my formula will be satisfied.
So I can go and say, well F1 was
actually this, and F2 was this,
and F3 was this.
So I can ask a theory solver, is
it possible to get an x and a y
such that x is greater
than 5, y is less than 5,
and y is greater than x?
Right, so now this is a question
purely about linear arithmetic.
There's no Boolean
logic involved.
And what's the answer?
No.
Right?
And there are
traditional methods
to solve these kinds
of your problems.
You could use the simplex
method, for example,
to solve systems of
linear inequalities.
There's lots of
methods that you can
use to solve systems
of linear inequalities.
The point is the theory solver
knows about all of those.
And the theory
solver can say, no.
This will not work.
This is an assignment
that will not work.
And so the theory solver can
now go back to the SAT solver
and not just tell the SAT
solver, hey, that thing
that you did, that didn't work.
But it can also give
more of an explanation.
So in this case, what you can
conclude from the fact that
this didn't work is that
actually in addition
to satisfying this formula you
also want to satisfy the fact
that I cannot have F1,
and F2, and F3, right?
My theory solver has
told me that these three
things are mutually exclusive.
I cannot satisfy all
three of them together.
And so now that's a
piece of information
that I can go back
to the SAT solver
and ask the SAT
solver, hey, can you
give me a solution
that satisfies
not only the constraint that
you had in the beginning,
but also this new
constraint that the theory
solver discovered?
Right?
So now is there some other
assignment that satisfies now
both of these constraints?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Yeah.
So there's an assignment
where this becomes false.
And this becomes true.
And that's an assignment
that satisfies
the constraint on the top.
It satisfies the
constraint on the bottom.
And so once again
that's an assignment
that leads to a new constraint.
So this constraint
now goes away.
We don't care about it any more.
We have a new constraint that we
can ask our theory solver, hey,
it this possible?
And in this case the
theory solver says, yeah.
That actually is possible.
You can make y equal
3 and x equal 6.
And it works.
Right?
And so now you
have an assignment
that satisfies the
formula in the theory
and that satisfies
the Boolean structure
behind this assignment.
And with that the system can
come back and tell you, yeah.
Here's an assignment that
satisfies all your constraints.
And so it's this
interaction back and forth
between the theory solver
and the SAT solver.
And really the ability
to be able to reason
about very, very large and very
complicated Boolean formulas.
That's what makes symbolic
execution possible.
So now that we have that
the next question is,
so how do we go from a
program to a constraint
that we can give
to an SMT solver?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry for going back.
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
previously.
But could you run me again the
whole issue of constructing
the SMT statements?
Is it an NP-complete or
is it not? [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
So the problems
that the SMT
solvers are solving,
those are NP-complete
problems in the best of cases.
So SAT itself is the
canonical NP-complete problem,
but a lot of solvers these
days even include support
for some theories that
are outright undecidable.
So--
AUDIENCE: So how do you
approach that in your system?
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Well, at
the end of the day what you get
is you're going to create a
constraint from this program.
You're going to give
it to the SMT solver.
And the fact that these
are NP-complete problems,
or the fact that they're
unsatisfiable, what it means
is that if you're lucky, you
will get an answer in seconds.
And if you're not
lucky, then it might
take longer than the age of
the universe for the thing
to give you an answer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
How often do you run into
cases where your system just
flat-lines and says, sorry, I
just can't figure this out yet?
Has that ever happened
or is that just--
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Yes.
Yes, it does happen.
And a big part of
the engineering
of these kind of
tools is making sure
that this happens as
infrequently as possible.
And part what makes
this work at all
is that we're not solving
random SAT problems.
We're not solving completely
random bit-vector problems.
We're solving problems that
have a certain structure to them
that a person was
able to look at it
and least have some confidence
that this worked, right?
Build some argument in their
head for why this worked.
And so what the solvers
are trying to do
is essentially exploiting
that structure.
And taking advantage, for
example, the description
that I gave you of what the
SAT solver is doing internally,
that's taking advantage
of the fact that, yes.
Your problem might have a
million Boolean variables,
but actually most
of those variables
are very tightly dependent
on the values of each other.
So the number of degrees
of freedom in the problem
is actually much smaller
than what the million
variables would suggest.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
is that this isn't an exam
question.
This is real life.
And someone built this system.
It was supposed to
work and make sense.
So it's probably
not going to be one
of those wildly bizarre
theoretical [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
That's right.
And in practice what
happens and when
you use this tool is the
thing is you always do
is set timeouts.
So generally, what happens
is because it's exponential,
exponential doesn't mean
that you can't do it.
Exponential just means
that there's a brick wall,
that before that brick
wall things will work,
and in fact, they
will work really fast.
Right?
The exponential
works in both ways.
Yes, when you're
going out then things
are growing very
quickly, but when
you're going toward smaller
problems, or simpler problems
things are also getting
faster very, very quickly.
So in general what that means
is that lots of problems
finish very, very quickly.
And then some problems timeout.
And the key is to engineer
things in such a way
that among the problems that
finish quickly are actually
problems of practical use.
Or problems that will
actually point you
to security vulnerabilities
in your system,
will point you to bugs,
will point you to a path
that you maybe haven't
explored before,
or inputs that will take
you down paths that you
hadn't explored before.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
Other questions?
All right.
So we know how to
go from a formula,
from a set of constraints, to
an answer that will either say,
yes, this formula
has a solution.
And here's a solution, or no,
this formula is unsatisfiable.
There is no input
that satisfies this.
So now how do we get a
formula from a program?
So one of the
things that you have
when you're doing
symbolic execution
is that when you get
to a branch and you
don't know which direction
the branch is going to go.
Now there are two possibilities
that you can do in that case.
One is to do what we did in the
early example, which is just
to say, I'm going to take both
branches at the same time.
I'm going to collect what
happens in mode's branches,
merge at the end.
That is a strategy
that is often used
when you're trying to get very
strong guarantees in general.
But it's a strategy that
doesn't work too well
with modern and SMT solvers.
So often people prefer to do
one path at a time exploration.
And what that means
is that you're
going to pick a path
down your program.
And then you're going to
create a formula for that path.
So you're going to ask, fine
me an input that goes down
this path and that
satisfies my constraint,
or that violates
my property, that
goes out of bounds in my buffer,
or that causes a null pointer
error.
And then if you
can't find one then
you try a different path
and a different path.
And you do these path
explorations one at a time.
So that's the strategy that
we're going to talk about now.
It's a little bit easier
to describe how to do it.
So let's say that we
have a problem like this.
So, by the way, I
switched representations.
So I'm not representing the
program as a block of code
and representing it as
a control flow graph.
Is everybody here familiar
with a control flow graph?
Or is anybody here not familiar
It's just a representation
of a program that
makes branches more explicit.
So let's pick a path.
And so let's say that we
care about this path, right,
a path that starts
at the beginning
and takes us all the way
down to the point where
we are asserting false.
And we want to know,
is this path feasible?
Could the program
go down this path?
So as we're going
down this program
we're going to keep two things.
We're going to keep
an environment that
keeps track of the
symbolic values
of the different variables.
And in addition to that,
we're going to keep around
an environment for constraints.
And these constraints
are essentially
going to keep track of
all the relationships
between these variables as
well as any assumptions,
whether they were
assumptions that
were made at the
beginning, or assumptions
that come from the branches
that you are taking.
So in this case, when
we start down this path
we get to t equals 0, so
our state is x, y, and 0.
And so far we have
no constraints
because we didn't have any
constraint in the beginning.
So now we're going
to take this branch
and, again, because we've
made a decision that we're
going to go down the
path to your right,
then we know that this
path will only happen when?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
That's right.
So we get our first constraint
that says, x is greater than y.
Right?
So now down here we're
looking at t equals y.
Now in this case because we're
going only one path at a time
we don't actually need to
introduce a new variable for t
necessarily.
We can just say, OK.
t is equal to y.
So that means that
t is no longer 0.
It's now y.
Right?
And then keep going.
We get to this point.
Now we hit another branch.
What's a new
assumption that we have
to make if we're assuming
that we went down this path?
Just t less than y, right?
And what is t?
Right.
So in fact if we look up
t, so t has the value y.
We look up y.
y also has the value of y.
So this constraint actually
translates to y less than y.
So what does this tell us?
It tells us that in order
to make it to this point,
in order to make it to a assert
false, all of those things
have to hold.
Can they hold?
Clearly not.
Right?
y less than y alone is
already sufficient for things
not to hold.
And so that tells us immediately
that this is unsatisfiable.
And this is often known
as a path condition.
This is a condition
that has to be
true in order for the
program to go down that path.
And so we know that this path
condition cannot be satisfied.
And therefore, that it's
impossible for the program
to take this path.
So this path is now
completely eliminated.
We know that this
path cannot be taken.
And, in fact, so
this constraint we're
actually going to just keep them
around as the condition itself.
All right?
So what about a different path?
So now we're trying this path.
So what would be the
path condition for this?
So, again, our symbolic
state starts with t equals 0,
and x and y equals to just
the variables x and y.
And now how does
the path constraint
look like in this case?
So by the time we get here how
does the path condition look
like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR LEZAMA: Right.
So in this case [INAUDIBLE]
this is true and this is false.
So in this case it says,
OK. x is greater than y.
And we are setting
t to be equal to x.
So then when we get here
we have x is less than y.
Right?
And once again it's very
clear that this path condition
is unsatisfiable.
Right?
We cannot have x greater than
y and x less than y at the same
time.
There's no assignment
to x that will satisfy
both of those constraints.
So what that tells us is, again,
that this other path is also
unsatisfiable.
And now at this
point we've actually
explored every possible path in
our program that could lead us
to this condition.
So we can actually
establish and certify
that there is no possible path
that will lead to an assertion
failure.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The way you
just presented it,
it makes it look as if you would
explore every possible branch.
I mean, one of the advantages
of symbolic execution
is that you're trying
to prevent [INAUDIBLE]
a need of exploring all possible
[INAUDIBLE] exponential.
So how are you avoiding
that over here?
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: That's
a very good question, right?
So in this case essentially
what you have is
you have a trade off between
high symbolic and how concrete
you want to be.
Right?
So in this case we are not
as symbolic as the first time
around when we were visiting
both branches at the same time,
but in exchange for that our
constraints became very, very
simple.
Right?
So the individual path by path
constraints are very simple,
but you have to do this over,
and over, and over again
to explore all the
different branches.
And there are exponentially--
all the different paths.
And there are exponentially
many paths in a program.
Now there are
exponentially many paths,
but for every path
in general, there's
also an exponentially
large set of inputs
that could go down that path.
So this already gives you a
big benefit because instead
of having to try every
possible input you're only
trying every possible path.
But can you do better?
And this is one of the
areas where there's
been a lot of experimentation in
the area of symbolic execution.
When you do path
by path reasoning?
When do you do all
paths at the same time?
And one of the things
that you saw, for example,
in the [? Clee ?] paper
is a set of heuristics,
and a set of
strategies they used
to make the search tractable.
For example, one of
the things that they do
is that they are
exploring path by path,
but they're not exploring
completely blindly.
And they are also checking
the path conditions
after every step.
So that, for example,
if here instead of just
assert false, if this were
a very complex program tree,
control flow graph.
You don't wait until
you get to the very end
to check whether the
path is feasible.
The moment you get here you know
that this path is unsatisfiable
and you never go
down this direction.
You always go in
the other direction.
So pruning the paths
early helps cut down a lot
on the experiential blow up.
And exploring the
paths intelligently
helps a lot in
preventing blow up.
A lot of the practical
tools that are used today,
some of the things
that they will do
is they will actually start
with some random testing
to get an initial set of paths.
And then they will start looking
for paths in the neighborhood
of those paths.
They will start asking questions
like, hey, the random execution
went down this branch.
What if I flip this branch?
What happens in those paths?
Can be particularly
useful, for example,
if we have a good test suite.
And you run your test suite
and you find, OK, there
is this piece of code that
nothing in my test suite
exercised.
So what you can do is you can
take the path that got closest
to exercising that,
and then ask, hey,
can I change this path so that
it goes down this direction
instead?
And so in general,
the moment you
try to do all paths
simultaneously
the constraints start
becoming intractable.
And it's the kind
of thing that you
can do if you're doing
one function at a time.
For example, if you're
doing one function at a time
then it is generally feasible
to explore all the paths
in a function together.
If you're trying to do
larger units, then generally
you have to go with path
by path exploration.
Are there other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You referenced
how [INAUDIBLE].
How does it do that again?
What's the [INAUDIBLE]?
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: So the
most important one really is
this idea that for every branch,
you check your constraints
to check whether that branch
can actually go both ways,
because if it cannot go both
ways then you save a lot just
going in this direction
of where it can't go.
Beyond that I don't remember
the specific strategy
that they use for searching
paths that are more
likely to give good results.
But pruning is really,
really important.
OK.
So far though we've been
talking mostly about toy code
in the sense that it's only
integer variables, branches,
very simple stuff.
Right?
What happens when you
have a program that
is more complicated?
And in particular, what happens
when you have a program that
involves the heap?
Right?
So the heap has
historically been
the bane of all program
analysis, analysis
that were so clean and so
elegant in the days of Fortran,
completely blow up when you
try to run them on a C program
where you're allocating
memory left and right.
And you have aliasing.
And you have all
the messiness that
comes with dealing with
program allocated memory.
And with pointers and
pointer arithmetic.
And this is one of the areas
where symbolic execution really
shines in the ability
to actually reason
about these kinds of programs.
So how do we do it?
Right, so let's forget now
for a moment about branches,
and control flow.
We have a trivially
simple program here.
All it's doing is it's
allocating some memory.
It's zeroing it out.
It's getting a new pointer
y from the pointer x.
It's writing something into y.
And then it's checking,
hey, is the value
stored at pointer y equal to
the value stored at pointer x?
And just from your
basic knowledge of C
you could see that, no.
Right, that this assertion is
actually violated because x got
zeroed out and y
has 25 in there,
but x is pointing to
a different location.
Right?
So far so good.
The way we're going to
model the heap and the way
the heap is modeled in
a lot of these systems
is by not thinking of
the heap as a heap,
but to thinking of
the heat the way
C likes for you to think
of the heap, which is just
a giant address base, a giant
array where you can put things
into.
So what does that mean?
It means that we can
think of our program
as having this very
big global array.
And we're just going
to call it MEM for now.
Right?
And it's an array that
essentially is going
to map addresses to values.
Right?
And what's an address?
Well, an address is
just a 64-bit value.
And what comes after you read
something from an address?
It depends on how
you're modeling memory.
If you're modeling it at the
byte level, then what comes out
is a byte.
If you're modeling it
at the word level then
what comes out of it is a word.
And depending on the kind of
bugs that you're interested in,
and whether things
like memory alignment
are an issue for
you are not, you're
going to model it a
little bit differently,
but generally memory
is just an array
from an address to a value.
Right?
So an address is
just an integer.
Right?
It's in some sense not
that different from the way
C thinks I'm an address.
It's just an integer.
It's just a value.
It's just a 64-bit integer,
or a 32-bit integer,
depending on your machine.
It just a value that
indexes into that memory.
And that you can put
things in memory,
read them from the memory.
So things like
pointer arithmetic
just becomes integer arithmetic.
In practice there's a
little bit of desugaring
that has to happen because in C
the pointer arithmetic actually
knows about the types
of the pointers.
And things will be incremented
proportional to the size,
right?
So this would actually be x
plus 10 times the size of int.
Right?
But what's really
important is what
happens when you're reading
and writing from memory.
So what used to be just a
pointer reference from y
to write 25, is now just
I'm taking my memory array,
and I'm indexing it with y.
And I'm writing 25 to
that memory location.
Right?
And this assertion
now becomes, well, I
am reading from
location y in memory.
And I am reading from
location x in memory.
And I am comparing them.
And I'm checking whether
they are the same or not.
It's a very, very
simple reduction
to go from program that uses the
heap to a program the just uses
this giant global array
that represents the memory.
And now what that
means is that in order
to reason about programs
that manipulate the heap
you don't really have
to reason about programs
that manipulate the heap.
As long as you have the
ability to reason about arrays,
you are good.
Now here's a simple
question though.
What about the malloc?
So one thing you can do is
you can say, well, malloc,
I can just take the C
implementation of malloc
and actually implement
malloc like that.
And keep track of all the
pages that I have allocated
and keep track of everything
that has been freed.
And keep a free
list, and everything.
It turns out for
a lot of purposes
and for a lot of
classes of bugs,
you don't need malloc
to be that complicated.
In fact, you can get away with
a malloc that looks like this,
with a malloc that
just says, I'm
going to keep a counter for
the next free memory location.
And whenever somebody
asks for an address,
that address I'm just
going to give this position
and then increment the position.
Right?
And then return
rv, in this case.
So one of the thing that is
malloc is completely ignoring.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: Yeah.
Freeing, right?
This malloc says, yeah,
forget about freeing.
There's no freeing.
We're just going to keep walking
through our memory allocating
further, and further, and
further and that will be it.
And we don't care
about freeing anything.
It also doesn't really
care about the fact
that well, actually, there
are regions of memory where
you shouldn't be writing.
There are special
addresses that have
special meaning that are
reserved for the operating
system.
It doesn't model
any of the things
that actually make writing a
malloc function complicated,
but at a certain
level of abstraction,
if you're trying to reason
about some complicated code that
does pointer manipulation.
And you don't care
about freeing memory,
but you really
care about is, am I
going to write past the end
of some buffer, for example.
Then this malloc
might be good enough.
And this is actually that
happens very, very commonly
when you're doing symbolic
execution of real code.
A very important
step is the modeling
of your library functions.
And how you model
your library functions
is going to have a huge
impact on the one hand
on the performance and the
scalability of the analysis,
but on the other hand,
on the precision.
So if you have a Mickey Mouse
model of malloc like this,
it's going to be
very, very fast,
but there are going to be
certain classes of bugs
that you won't be able to catch.
Right?
So and this model, for
example, I'm completely
ignoring the allocations.
So if I have a bug
because somebody
is accessing unallocated space.
Well, I'm not going to find
it with this Mickey Mouse
model of malloc.
Right?
So it's always a balance between
the precision of the analysis
versus the efficiency.
And the more complicated your
models of standard functions
like malloc get,
the less scalable
the analysis is going to be,
but for certain classes of bugs
you will need those models.
And one of the big things
in the [? Clee ?] paper
was really having
reasonable models
for all the different
libraries in C,
all the different
libraries that are
needed in order to understand
what a program is actually
doing.
So, OK.
So we've reduced the problem
of reasoning about the heap
to a problem of reasoning
about a program with arrays,
but I haven't actually
told you how to reason
about a program with arrays.
And it turns out
that most SMT solvers
support a theory of arrays.
And the idea is
if a is an array,
there's some notation to
say, well, take that array
and create a new array
where location i has
been updated to value e.
All right?
So if I have array a and I
do this update operation,
and then I try to
read the value k,
then the meaning
is that the value k
is going to be
equal to the value k
at a if k is different from i.
And it's going to be equal to
e if k is equal to i, right?
That's what updating
an array means.
That's what it means
to take an old array
and update it to be a new array.
And the nice thing about this is
that if you have a formula that
involves the theory of
arrays, so, for example,
I started with the zero array
that is just zeros everywhere.
And then I wrote 5 into location
i, and 7 into location j.
And then I'm reading from k.
And then I'm checking whether
that's equal to 5 or not.
Then that can be expanded
by using this definition
to something that says,
well, if k is equal to i
then if k is equal to y,
and k is different from j,
then, yes, this is
going to be equal to 5.
And otherwise this is not
going to be equal to 5, right?
And in practice SMT solvers
don't just expand these
into lots of Boolean formulas.
They, again, use
this back and forth
strategy between a SAT
solver and an engine
that is able to reason about
this theory of arrays in order
to do it.
But what's important
is that by relying
on this theory of arrays,
using the same strategy we
saw to generate formulas for
integers you can actually
generate formulas
involving array logic,
and involving array updates,
involving array axises,
involving iteration over arrays
as long as you fix your path,
these formulas are
very easy to generate.
If you don't fix
your paths if you
want to generate a
formula that corresponds
to going through all paths,
then it's also relatively easy.
The Only thing is you
have to deal with loops
in more of a special way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA:
I don't know.
So dictionaries and
maps are actually
very easy to model using
uninterpreted functions.
And, in fact, the
theory of arrays
itself, it's just a special
case of uninterpreted functions.
So more complicated
things can be done
with uninterpreted functions.
In modern SMT solvers
there is native support
for reasoning about
sets and set operations,
which can be very, very
useful if you're reasoning
about a program that involves
lots of set computations,
for example.
When designing
one of these tools
the modeling step
is really important.
And it's not just how you model
complicated program features
down to your theories.
So, for example, things
like heaps down to arrays.
And also the choice of what
theories and the solver you
use.
And there's a large number
of theories and the solver
with different trade offs
between how efficient they are
versus how expressive they are.
And, in general, most
of the production tools
stick to the theory
of bit-vectors
and they might use
the theory of arrays
to model the heap if
that is necessary.
Generally production
tools try to shy away
from some of the more
sophisticated theories,
like the theory of sets
just because by virtue
being richer they also tend to
be less scalable in some cases,
unless you're dealing with a
program that really requires
exactly that kind of reasoning
in order to work with.
Are there other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] research
in symbolic execution,
what are people
focusing on and where
is there room for improvement?
[INAUDIBLE] applications.
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: So one
very active area of research
is around applications.
And looking at models
that will allow
you to discover new
classes of bugs.
So, for example, Nikolai,
and Franz, and Xi Wang and I
had a paper, what
was it, last year
when we were looking at using
symbolic execution to identify
coding your program that a
compiler might optimize away.
Security checks that might get
optimized away by a compiler.
So it's very different from the
question of will the program go
down this path or not, but
there is a modeling step
to go from this high
level conceptual question
of, is there a
code in my program
that can be compiled away
to an algorithm based
on symbolic execution
that will rely
on the ability of
symbolic execution
to easily tell you whether
the program can go down
a particular path, or whether
a particular path is feasible.
So applications is a
big area, extending
to newer classes
of bugs, growing
to new and different
language features.
For example, one of the
things that is still
fairly hard to model from
using symbolic execution
are very high level languages,
like JavaScript or Python where
you have a lot of very
dynamic language features,
but at the same time they
are-- if any technique can
work for the symbolic execution,
it's definitely very good.
And, in fact, we had some
work a couple of years
ago using symbolic
execution to reason
about errors in Python
programming assignments,
for example.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
How does [INAUDIBLE]?
ARMANDO SOLAR-LEZAMA: It is.
So in the case of symbolic
execution part of the problem
is that your symbolic state,
it's very hard to simply say,
OK, I executed this
instruction, and then
this instruction, and
then this instruction.
The sequence is not there.
There was some work a few
years ago looking, for example,
at very small pieces of
code, but very critical,
like a concurring data
structure in operating
system, or lock-free
data structure
and modeling the
interactions between threads
by essentially saying, every
time there is a variable that
could have been overwritten
by something else,
you replace that value with
just a fresh symbolic value that
says, I have no
idea what this is.
And you generate
constraints that
relate to those symbolic
values to symbolic values
in other threads.
And this has been
used even to reason
about things like missing
memory fences, for example.
And so it is possible, but the
complexity grows quite a bit.
And it becomes the kind of thing
that you cannot no longer do
at the scale of Microsoft Word,
but you can do at the scale
of, say, a concurring data
structure, for example.
There had been other work though
in the context of concurrency
looking at, for example,
can I use symbolic execution
to reconstruct
interleavings based
on knowledge of how the program
behaved as it was running,
for example.
And so this opens a
lot of possibilities,
having this capability to
ask very concrete questions
about can my program
run down this path.
Being able to have
symbolic values
and ask questions, what values
should these things have
in order for the program to
do something, or in order
something to happen is a
very powerful capability
and there's a lot
of applications
that have been tried, but
this is a fairly new piece
of technology as
far as technology
for analyzing a program goes.